I think I'm a pretty good judge of character and I love sharing tips and tricks with people which genuinely help them to run their clinical practices more efficiently. This episode is supported by WriteUp and they're a brand I've been using in my own clinical practice for over six years. I really do genuinely rate them and use the Write Up platform for each and every clinic session I book or conduct. That's why I'm so happy to be working with them. In case you don't know already, Write Up is an all in one practice. management platform built in the UK for UK clinicians. So that's your diary, your client records, your notes, your invoicing, your secure messaging, all in one place, all GDPR compliant,
我认为自己看人很准，而且我乐于分享一些切实可行的小窍门，帮助人们更高效地经营临床诊所。本期节目由 WriteUp 赞助，这是我在自己的临床诊所中已经使用了六年多的品牌。我确实非常认可他们，并且在我预约或进行的每一次诊疗中都会使用 WriteUp 平台。这就是我非常乐意与他们合作的原因。如果你还不了解，WriteUp 是一个一体化的诊所管理平台，专为英国临床医生在英国打造。它涵盖了你的日程安排、客户记录、笔记、发票、安全通讯，所有功能集于一身，且完全符合 GDPR 标准。
all designed around the way we actually practice. Also, news just in, they've recently launched an AI scribe that drafts your session notes for you and a tap to pay app that turns your smartphone into a card reader. Both are the kind of small changes that quietly give you, hours back every week. But don't worry if you don't want to use all of those features, you don't have to either. If you've been meaning to sort your admin out or you're stuck wrestling with a system that wasn't built for you, take a look at writeup.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P dot com. And when you use my code, Marianne 30, you can access a free 30-day trial with 30% off for six months for up to six users.
所有设计都围绕着我们实际的执业方式。另外，最新消息是，他们最近推出了 AI 记录员，可以为你起草诊疗笔记，还有一个“点击支付”应用程序，能将你的智能手机变成读卡器。这两者都是那种能让你每周悄悄省下几小时的小改变。但如果你不想使用所有这些功能，也没关系，不必强求。如果你一直想整理行政工作，或者正被一套不适合你的系统折磨，不妨看看 writeup.com。网址是 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P 点 com。使用我的代码 Marianne 30，你可以获得 30 天免费试用，并在六个月内享受 30% 的折扣，最多支持六个用户。
What's not to like. Now on with the show. When it comes to physical health, people are so often told your tests are normal. And of course, what they then hear is, so this is all in your head. But what if that's based on a complete misunderstanding for how the body and mind actually work together? In this episode, health psychologist Dr. Sula Wingasen and I explore pain, chronic illness, UTIs, adenomyosis and so much. more. We grapple with why feeling dismissed can be so psychologically devastating and how people can begin to take control once more.
何乐而不为呢？现在开始节目。谈到身体健康时，人们经常被告知“你的检查结果很正常”。当然，他们随后听到的潜台词就是：“所以这都是你的心理作用。”但如果这种说法完全误解了身心协同工作的方式呢？在本期节目中，健康心理学家 Sula Wingasen 博士和我将探讨疼痛、慢性病、尿路感染、子宫腺肌症等等。我们将深入探讨为什么感到被忽视会带来如此巨大的心理打击，以及人们如何才能重新开始掌控自己的生活。
Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm joined here today by Dr. Sula Wyngasen who is a health psychologist. Hi Sula. Hi, thanks for having me. Thank you for being here. You first took my attention because of thinking about I think some of your personal struggles with health. and perhaps why you got into kind of health psychology to begin with. Could you guide us through a little bit of that? Yeah, absolutely. So I started having problems when I was in my early 20s after graduating my psychology degree,
大家好，欢迎收听《心理学实际上》。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，今天和我在一起的是健康心理学家 Sula Wyngasen 博士。你好，Sula。你好，谢谢邀请我来。谢谢你的到来。你最初引起我的注意是因为我了解到你个人在健康方面的一些挣扎，以及你最初为何投身于健康心理学。你能带我们了解一下这段经历吗？好的，没问题。我是在 20 多岁、心理学学位毕业后开始出现问题的。
which started with recurrent urinary tract infections. They would come, they would kind of clear up with antibiotics, but then they'd come back and they evolved and changed and then started confusing people and doctors. I was in and out of different departments trying to get answers and not really getting any. And that whole experience made me incredibly depressed and hopeless. And I think being in that place for a relatively short period of time compared to, you know, what I know it can be like for lots of other people, just really shocked my system.
起初是反复发作的尿路感染。它们会来，用抗生素治疗后会好转，但随后又会复发，并且不断演变，开始让医生和周围的人感到困惑。我频繁出入不同的科室试图寻找答案，却始终一无所获。整个经历让我感到无比沮丧和绝望。我认为，与我知道的许多其他人所经历的相比，在那种状态下待上一段相对较短的时间，就已经对我的系统造成了巨大的冲击。
And when I started getting support and little rungs that gave me a little bit of hope, which allowed me to start changing things, when I got a bit of momentum with that and I started recovering, it solidified to me that I really had to understand why I was getting better. And a lot of that was to do with health psychology and these mind-body processes. So I went back to do a master's at King's College London in Health Psychology to explore that or more. But I think the thing that I come back to again and again, because I loved health psychology at undergrad, which was just one module that I was taught.
当我开始获得支持，并找到了一些给我带来希望的支撑点，让我能够开始改变现状时，随着我取得了一些进展并开始康复，我更加坚信我必须弄清楚自己为什么会好转。这很大程度上与健康心理学和这些身心过程有关。所以我回到伦敦国王学院攻读了健康心理学硕士学位，以进一步探索这一点。但我认为，我一次又一次回想起的事情是，我在本科时就爱上了健康心理学，尽管当时只学了一门课。
But I didn't know it was a career. And who knows what would have happened if I wouldn't have got ill, but it really, yeah, it really has given me the passion and undying interest in all of these processes. Yeah, I should just say for our audience, if anyone's interested in hearing more about the psychology kind of career for health psychology. There's another video on health psychology and it as a career, which I will link in the show notes. Okay, so, you know, the title of your book's very clever. Well done. Don't know if it's your idea or your publishers.
但我当时并不知道这可以成为一种职业。谁知道如果我没有生病会发生什么呢？但它确实给了我对所有这些过程的热情和永恒的兴趣。是的，我应该对我们的听众说，如果有人有兴趣了解更多关于健康心理学职业的信息，我会在节目说明中链接另一个关于健康心理学职业的视频。好的，那么，你书的标题非常巧妙。做得好。不知道这是你的主意还是你出版商的主意。
So it's all in your body, which of course is kind of a little tongue-in-cheek play around with that term that you probably perhaps did hear yourself like it's all in your mind. But what I really liked about this book is that it really kind of de-shames the person's experience. So I'm reading it as someone that has a physical health diagnosis themselves. We might cover that shortly. But also I'm reading it as a clinician and thinking about, oh, I've never actually thought about the impact of psoriasis and migraines and kind of recurrent, you know, urine retract infection. So I really liked it from kind of that perspective. But it's that, it's that pivot. It's a gentle, curious holding of the idea that maybe this isn't just about you and the way you're thinking about something that I
书名是《一切都在你的身体里》，这当然是对那句你可能也听过的话——“一切都在你的脑子里”——的一种俏皮的调侃。但我真正喜欢这本书的地方在于，它真正消除了人们经历中的羞耻感。我作为一个本身就有身体健康诊断的人在读它，我们稍后可能会谈到这一点。但我也是以临床医生的身份在阅读，我在想，哦，我以前从未真正思考过银屑病、偏头痛和反复尿路感染带来的影响。所以我真的很喜欢这个视角。但关键在于那种转变，一种温和、好奇地持有这样一种观点：也许这不仅仅是你个人的问题，也不是你思考问题的方式，我认为这非常有力，Sula。
think is really powerful, Sula. Yeah. I mean, that phrase, it's all in your head is something that people do explicitly get told, but often they implicitly have it, you know, communicated to them, the tests came back normal. So therefore, this is a mental figment of your imagination, or this is a stress problem, or this is an anxiety problem. And what I explained in the book is that because we're socialized to think about the mind and body as very separate things, what that infers is A, this has got nothing to do with biological processes and B, this is all your fault then. Like it's your thinking error, it's your feeling error and you've got ultimate responsibility over that. But if we actually understand how interrelated our psychological experiences are
是的。我的意思是，“一切都在你的脑子里”这句话，人们确实会被明确告知，但通常他们也会隐晦地感受到这一点，比如“检查结果正常，所以这是你想象出来的，或者是压力问题，或者是焦虑问题”。我在书中解释说，因为我们被社会化教育认为身心是完全分离的，所以这意味着：A，这与生物过程无关；B，这完全是你自己的错。就像这是你的思维错误、情感错误，而你要对此负全部责任。但如果我们真正理解我们的心理体验与我们的生物学，与我们身体内正在发生的生物学过程是多么紧密地相互关联，
with our biology, with what's happening biologically in our body, very physically, then that phrase, it's all in your head, becomes a nonsense because everything is all in our heads, bodies and wherever else it's being transmitted, you know, our thoughts are physical processes, our emotions of physical processes, and we just can't unentwine, you know, one thing from another. But the other thing is when we recognize that there is this ongoing interrelationship between these two things, but you also recognize that you can't dichotomize the cause like that, because, you know, even for somebody that's got an observable, injury, tissue damage or what have you. Yes, there's very biological, observable processes going on that
那么“一切都在你的脑子里”这句话就变得毫无意义了，因为一切都在我们的头脑、身体以及其他任何传输信息的地方。你知道，我们的思想是物理过程，我们的情绪是物理过程，我们无法将一件事与另一件事剥离。但另一件事是，当我们认识到这两者之间存在这种持续的相互关系时，你也会意识到你不能像那样将原因二分，因为，你知道，即使对于一个有明显损伤、组织受损或类似情况的人来说。是的，确实有非常生物学、可观察的过程在发生，
you could see, you know, if you were to open up the body or on a scan perhaps. But there's also additional processes, biological processes that we can't easily see that are massively impacted by how that person's feeling about that injury, how they're behaving around that injury, are they going back to try and work out too soon? Are they completely resting up so that they don't cause any injury about their perception of what that pain means, whether it means I'm healing or whether it means things are going to get worse. All of that has an effect physiologically in the body. And it's all of these multiple different elements that ultimately influence, you know, what happens with our physical experience as much as our psychological experience.
如果你打开身体或者通过扫描可能就能看到。但还有额外的过程，我们无法轻易看到的生物过程，它们受到那个人对伤痛的感受、围绕伤痛的行为方式的巨大影响。他们是否太快尝试恢复工作？他们是否完全静养以至于不造成任何伤害？他们对这种疼痛意味着什么的感知，是意味着我在愈合，还是意味着情况会恶化。所有这些在生理上都会对身体产生影响。正是所有这些多种不同的因素，最终影响了我们的身体体验，就像它们影响我们的心理体验一样。
Yeah. And I think some of the trickier aspects of this is like you said, you know, when you become that head scratcher case that the medics are like, oh, I don't know then. Like, I don't know why this is happening. And when it comes to autoimmune conditions, you know, like inflammatory bowel disease or, you know, things like chronic fatigue syndrome or, you know, other conditions that people are like fibromyalgia, for example, that feels very judgy. It feels like it's about something that you've done before or you're using your thoughts incorrectly or your, you're somehow mismanaging your body and and then that's leading to that and because there's not always that treatment there isn't always the magic pill I think probably similar to me with I've got a
是的。我认为其中一些棘手的地方在于，就像你说的，当你成为医生们抓耳挠腮的病例时，他们会说：“哦，那我不知道了。”就像，“我不知道为什么会这样。”当涉及到自身免疫性疾病时，比如炎症性肠病，或者慢性疲劳综合征，或者像纤维肌痛这样的疾病，人们会觉得这非常有评判性。感觉就像是你之前做过什么，或者你错误地使用了你的思想，或者你以某种方式管理不当你的身体，从而导致了这种情况。而且因为并不总是有那种治疗方法，并不总是有灵丹妙药，我想可能和我类似，我有一种
condition called adenomyosis you just get stuck with it holding it thinking well I just have to accept it and just put up with it however bad that gets it's so hard because one of the things that I try and straddle in the book is this heightened sense of responsibility and, you know, the knife edge of that being flipping over into self-blame or self-criticism because of precisely these wider social experiences of health. So if you went to the healthcare system and you were told, right, you've got inflammatory biol disease, this is what it is, this is what the treatment path looks like, this is what we're going to do to help you manage. But alongside that, we know that we know that. We know that stress physically affects the body. And so these are some things we can give you support with.
叫做子宫腺肌症的疾病，你只能被困在其中，心想“我只能接受它，忍受它，无论它变得多糟糕”。这太难了，因为我在书中试图平衡的一件事就是这种高度的责任感，以及这种责任感滑向自我指责或自我批评的边缘，这正是因为这些更广泛的健康社会经历。所以，如果你去了医疗系统，被告知：“好吧，你患有炎症性肠病，这就是它，治疗路径是这样的，我们将采取这些措施来帮助你管理。”但与此同时，我们知道压力在生理上会影响身体。所以我们可以为你提供一些支持。
That is not at all stigmatizing. It's supportive. It's not being like, this is all on you to figure out. And so we can perhaps cope better and have more optimal outcomes in that scenario. But the problem is, again, people experience varying kinds of support with IBD. It tends to be better than if somebody gets condition diagnosed, I mean, yeah, like adenomyosis or endometriosis, often that's just put on the table as you've got this, we'll probably be able to manage it with hormones, maybe, or if you're lucky, or you get denied that you have anything for a long time until, you know, there's some kind of definitive thing that often is from you pushing for it. And the journey of that then implies this is not our problem as the medical system.
那一点也不带有污名化，而是支持性的。它不会让你觉得“这一切都要靠你自己去解决”。所以我们或许能更好地应对，并在那种情况下获得更理想的结果。但问题是，人们在炎症性肠病方面获得的各种支持是不一样的。它往往比那些被诊断出患有子宫腺肌症或子宫内膜异位症的人要好。通常这只是被摆在桌面上说：“你得了这个，我们可能可以用激素来控制它，也许吧。”或者如果你幸运的话，或者你很长一段时间都被否认患有任何疾病，直到出现某种明确的东西，而这通常是你争取来的。而这段旅程暗示着：这不是我们医疗系统的问题，
system, this is your problem, and it's all on you to figure that out. And when you finally do, yeah, if it's met with a lack of sense of, here's the appropriate treatment pathway, and by the way, this is probably being very stressful for you, and it's probably changed your life in lots of different ways. These are some things that we'd suggest, and these are some support services you can get to help you adjust to the life changes that you've had, that would be so much more destigmatizing and I don't think people would grapple so much with, oh, it's my fault then. It's this culture of, no, you don't have anything, no, you don't have anything, oh yeah, you do have something, and lack of continuity of care, which feeds this message of it's all on you.
这是你的问题，一切都要靠你自己去解决。当你最终解决时，如果它没有得到“这是适当的治疗路径，顺便说一下，这对你来说可能压力很大，它可能以许多不同的方式改变了你的生活。这些是我们建议的一些事情，这些是你为了适应生活变化可以获得的支持服务”这种回应，那会更具去污名化效果。我不认为人们会如此纠结于“哦，那是我的错”。这是一种“不，你没病，不，你没病，哦，是的，你确实有病”的文化，以及缺乏护理的连续性，这助长了“一切都要靠你自己”的信息。
So a big point that I make in the book is, yes, there are things that we can do to work with our bodies and to work with our psychological experience of the difficulties that arise when health, you know, is impacted. And that's super important because it has protective benefits and it helps us with healing and recovery, whatever that looks like in the various different forms. But we shouldn't be putting all the responsibility on ourselves. We do actually need social safety. And that looks like supportive friends, supportive partners, a healthcare system that actually can meet you and support you rather than, you know, leave you feeling like you're on your own with this to figure out. and unfortunately there are systemic issues that makes that hard to access a lot of the time.
所以我在书中提出的一个重要观点是，是的，我们可以做一些事情来与我们的身体合作，并处理当健康受到影响时出现的心理困难。这非常重要，因为它具有保护作用，并有助于我们的愈合和康复，无论它以各种不同的形式表现出来。但我们不应该把所有的责任都推给自己。我们确实需要社会安全感。这看起来像是支持性的朋友、支持性的伴侣，以及一个真正能理解并支持你的医疗系统，而不是让你觉得只能独自面对这一切。不幸的是，存在系统性问题，使得这在很多时候很难获得。
Yeah, absolutely. And I think because we are all so different, but we, I think can sometimes struggle with kind of that theory of mind in thinking that anyone else has had a different experience to us. And, you know, when it comes to things like periods, you know, I think I just always thought, even from my teenage years, that everybody else had really awful, painful periods.
是的，绝对是。而且我认为因为我们每个人都如此不同，但我认为我们有时会难以理解那种“心智理论”，即认为其他人有与我们不同的经历。而且，你知道，当涉及到像月经这样的事情时，我想我一直认为，即使从青少年时期开始，其他所有人都有非常糟糕、痛苦的月经。
So even when I was a teenager, I spoke to one of my childhood friends about this recently. I was like, do you remember on the first day of every period, I'd be ill from school because I'd be being sick. I'd be being physically vomiting. She's like, yeah, like you really struggled, didn't you? But I just thought everyone did. And then, yeah, like really painful periods.
所以即使在我十几岁的时候，我最近和一位童年朋友谈起这件事。我说：“你还记得每个月经的第一天，我都会因为生病而不能上学吗？因为我会呕吐。我会身体上呕吐。”她说：“是的，你确实很痛苦，不是吗？”但我只是以为每个人都这样。然后，是的，就像非常痛苦的月经。
But in the end, I stopped taking kind of even any painkillers. So I just thought, well, this is just something I've got to put up with and deal with and learn and accept. And I think they haven't always been super heavy. They've got much heavier as I've got older. And I don't know if it's because I've had two cesarean sections as well, and that hasn't helped matters. But what I also didn't realize until I googled even last, I think it was last month,
但最终，我甚至停止服用任何止痛药。所以我只是想，好吧，这只是我必须忍受、处理、学习和接受的事情。而且我认为它们并不总是非常严重。随着年龄的增长，它们变得严重多了。我不知道是不是因为我也做了两次剖腹产，那并没有改善情况。但我直到上个月谷歌搜索时才意识到，
that adenomyosis is probably one of the reasons why I'm never going to have a flat stomach, at least while I'm still menstruating, because actually you're more likely to have, you know, to look about four and a half months pregnant, which I do. And which kindly a young child did say to me. recently. Are you seeing a baby? And it's like, oh, no, I'm not, I'm not that judgment and that blame and that kind of internal. I go, I go to the gym, like a, you know, few times a week. And why have I not got a flat stomach? Because I work hard and I, you know, I eat reasonably well.
子宫腺肌症可能是我永远不会有平坦小腹的原因之一，至少在我还在月经期间是这样，因为实际上你更有可能看起来像怀孕了四个月半，而我确实如此。而且一位年幼的孩子最近确实对我说了。你怀了宝宝吗？这就像，哦，不，我没有，那种评判和指责，以及那种内在的。我去健身房，就像，你知道，一周几次。为什么我没有平坦的小腹？因为我努力工作，而且我吃得还算不错。
And yeah, like, for me, learning, well, that's, that's, that's likely why has been useful. But I was never, I wasn't told that at the point that I was diagnosed. I was literally just told the name and that's probably that's it then there you go it's terrible really isn't it because it's such a big diagnosis to get and to receive it without any information any checking out you know what what care needs might you need from this or what your options might be again it all feeds into that sense of also you know if anything's to change it's all on me it's a reality at that point because nobody's doing anything for you, no one's saying, let me help you understand this.
是的，对我来说，了解这很可能是原因，这很有用。但我从未被告知，在我被诊断出来的时候。我只是被告知了名字，然后可能就是这样了，就这样吧。这真的很糟糕，不是吗？因为这是一个如此重大的诊断，在没有任何信息、没有任何检查的情况下接受它，你知道，你可能需要什么护理需求，或者你的选择可能是什么。同样，这一切都助长了那种感觉，即“如果有什么要改变，那全靠我自己”。在那一刻，这是一种现实，因为没有人为你做任何事，没有人说：“让我帮你理解这一点。”
And also the interesting thing there, Marianne, when you're talking about assuming it's normal, we have so much of that, again, natural disposition, you know, we're like lobsters in a pot, slowly being boiled alive, we don't realize, you know, we get big tolerance to these things and assume, well, this is just the way it is, especially if we're not having conversations, like no one's having conversations with us about what's normal, what's not normal, what requires or deserves extra looking into.
而且那里有趣的事情是，Marianne，当你谈到假设它是正常的时候，我们有太多那种自然的倾向，你知道，我们就像锅里的龙虾，慢慢地被活活煮死，我们没有意识到，我们对这些事情有了很大的容忍度，并假设“好吧，这就是现状”，特别是如果我们没有进行对话，没有人与我们讨论什么是正常的，什么是不正常的，什么需要或值得额外关注。
And as children, as teenagers, we're the least well equipped to advocate for ourselves potentially because we just don't have any point of reference. And so unfortunately, this is, you know, such a common story for conditions like adenomyiosis and endometriosis because there's the gender issue as well of like women's suffering is normal. you know, it's just periods. That's just what it is. You just have to get on with it. And women are so socialised not to make a fuss and be a burden. So we, yeah, we internalise. And that's made more difficult because then often when people have gone to the doctor, even early on in their, in their journey in adolescence or what have you, a lot of the time, the same message comes back of like, I will, you know, at best we'll put you on the pill, but there's no, like, let's explore this a little bit more. And so the theme that comes up again and again, which I talk about in the book and
作为孩子，作为青少年，我们最没有能力为自己辩护，因为我们没有任何参考点。所以不幸的是，对于子宫腺肌症和子宫内膜异位症这样的疾病，这是一个非常普遍的故事，因为还有性别问题，比如“女性的痛苦是正常的”。你知道，这只是月经。这就是它。你只需要忍受它。女性被社会化教育不要大惊小怪，不要成为负担。所以我们，是的，我们内化了。这变得更加困难，因为当人们去看医生时，即使在她们的旅程早期，在青春期或类似的时候，很多时候，同样的信息又回来了，比如“好吧，充其量我们给你开避孕药”，但没有“让我们再深入探讨一下”。所以我在书中谈到的，以及
which comes up again and again in my clinic is, you know, this sense of insignificance and not really important. Like, whatever you're dealing with isn't that important to anyone else. It's just, and if you're having an issue with it, well, that's your thing and you just need to work that out on your own, which is such a threatening experience. And I talk about how when we think about trauma, we think about, you know, the being in amongst all of the physical suffering maybe. But I hypothesize and we're doing some research, my colleagues and I at Kings at the moment, to explore this a little bit more. I hypothesize that actually one of the things that kind of embeds the traumatic nature of this in the brain is the fact of there's suffering plus the message surrounding the brain. that of you're not going to be helped so you're stuck with this and that's truly you know
在我的诊所里一次又一次出现的主题是，这种微不足道感，感觉自己不重要。就像，无论你在处理什么，对其他人来说都不重要。而且如果你对此有疑问，好吧，那是你自己的事，你需要自己解决。这是一种非常具有威胁性的经历。我谈到了当我们思考创伤时，我们想到的是，你知道，可能身处所有身体痛苦之中。但我假设，而且我和我的同事们目前在国王学院正在做一些研究来进一步探索这一点，我假设实际上，在脑海中嵌入这种创伤性质的事情之一是：痛苦加上围绕大脑的信息。那就是你不会得到帮助，所以你被困在这里了，这真是，你知道，
horrifying how you know you can suffer and be like well at least i know that i've got this care and that's so relieving but if the message coming back again and again is it's all on you and nobody else is going to save you that's that's really really scary and causes extreme stress and we know that the brain kind of changes how it processes things when when under extreme stress and that's such a repeated and common experience unfortunately yeah And I only went to the doctors about this when I was 43, I think. And that's because I thought I was having some symptoms that indicated the perimenopause. But I probably started my periods when I was 13 or 14.
令人恐惧。你知道，你可以受苦并想：“好吧，至少我知道我有这种护理”，这让人感到宽慰。但如果一次又一次传回的信息是“一切都要靠你自己，没有人会救你”，那真是太可怕了，会导致极端的压力。我们知道大脑在极端压力下会改变处理事物的方式，不幸的是，这是一种如此重复和普遍的经历。是的，我是在 43 岁时才去看医生的。那是因为我以为我有一些表明围绝经期的症状。但我可能在 13 或 14 岁时就开始月经了。
So that's, you know, 30 years that I just chugged on with it. And, you know, maybe there was treatment. Maybe there wasn't treatment. I guess I perhaps thought, well, maybe the treatment would be removed my uterus. and I don't want that because I want children. But, yeah, like, people aren't asking you generally, how are your periods? Like, that's just not something that we ask each other even as women, I don't think. No, it's not.
所以那是，你知道，30 年来我只是硬撑着。而且，你知道，也许有治疗方法。也许没有治疗方法。我想我可能认为，好吧，也许治疗方法是切除我的子宫。我不想要那样，因为我想要孩子。但是，是的，人们通常不会问你：“你的月经怎么样？”因为我认为即使作为女性，我们也不会互相问这个问题。不，不是。
Yeah, there's such a role for increasing awareness and having these conversations. But it's tricky because, in fact, I presented something recently to the pelvic pain network. and I think to a conference as well, where we've got this interesting thing at the moment of a disparity between the increasing awareness of some of these issues, including gender health inequality, but we are not seeing any change to systems or policy or care. And that actually creates more problems because you have higher threat anticipation. I'm not going to be helped. and then you have that actual experience. So we do need systemic things to start shifting.
是的，提高意识和进行这些对话的作用很大。但这很棘手，事实上，我最近向盆腔疼痛网络做了一些介绍，我想也向一个会议做了介绍，我们目前有一个有趣的事情，即在提高对其中一些问题的认识（包括性别健康不平等）与我们没有看到系统、政策或护理的任何改变之间存在差异。这实际上造成了更多的问题，因为你有更高的威胁预期。我不会得到帮助，然后你就有那种实际的经历。所以我们确实需要系统性的东西开始转变。
We do. And I think growing up and even, you know, if you watch a few TikToks or Instagram wheels, it's thought that a really good partner is the sort of partner that when you're having a period, we'll go out to the corner shop and buy you some chocolate and make sure you've got a hot water bottle and, you know, get your favourite sweets
我们确实需要。而且我认为在成长过程中，甚至，你知道，如果你看几个 TikTok 或 Instagram 短视频，人们认为一个好的伴侣是那种当你来月经时，会去街角商店给你买巧克力，确保你有热水袋，你知道，给你买你最喜欢的糖果，
and, you know, give you the remote control. And one of the things that really struck me about your book is maybe when it comes to periods, some of that might actually make it worse. Can I ask you to explain a little bit about what I mean, Sula? Yeah, let me give some context. So in the book, I talk about this process of psychobiological loops. So what I mean by that is we have, let's say, changed physiology because of something like hormonal fluctuations at different points. parts of our cycle. And as a result, we'll then have changes to our psychology. That will be like our preferences, what we're seeking. It will be, you know, our emotions, of course. Like most women,
而且，你知道，把遥控器给你。而我在你的书中真正印象深刻的一件事是，也许当涉及到月经时，其中一些实际上可能会让情况变得更糟。我可以请你解释一下我的意思吗，Sula？好的，让我提供一些背景。在书中，我谈到了心理生物学循环的过程。我的意思是，我们有，比如说，因为激素波动等原因而改变的生理机能。作为结果，我们的心理就会发生变化。那将是我们的偏好，我们在寻求什么。那将是，你知道，我们的情绪，当然。像大多数女性一样，
I would imagine, can have that reference point of coming on their period and having some kind of mood change. For me, it was like extreme rage and then being like, oh, I don't know, a few days later when it all cleared being like, hmm, I don't know why that made me so angry. So we have these changes that are influenced by changes in our physiology, but the changes to our psychology can then also impact our physiology. So, you know, that's a good example of hormonal fluctuations might increase anger or sadness. You then naturally can react on that basis. So maybe that's having a big argument or snapping at your partner or it might be, you know, being very tearful. And some of that's absolutely fine, but some of it might actually then cause difficulty.
我想象，可以有那种月经来潮并伴有某种情绪变化的参考点。对我来说，就像极度的愤怒，然后几天后当一切都过去时，会想：“嗯，我不知道为什么那让我那么生气。”所以我们有受生理变化影响的变化，但我们的心理变化也可以影响我们的生理。所以，你知道，这是一个很好的例子，激素波动可能会增加愤怒或悲伤。你然后自然地可以在此基础上做出反应。所以也许那是和你的伴侣大吵一架，或者对他们发火，或者可能是，你知道，变得非常爱哭。其中一些完全没问题，但其中一些实际上可能会导致困难。
So let's say like interpersonally, if you have argument with your partner and they're not particularly understanding and, you know, having a bad time themselves, then that will create tension. That adds stress. That then feeds into our physiology. And so we then, you know, have this like building snowball effect of different factors feeding into, you know, just the baseline changes in physiology. And then one of the points that I make in the book is that sometimes these, you know, changes in our physiology that we've got no real control over just is the way it happens, end up steering us down roots that aren't particularly helpful for us. So in regards to menstruation, I think I give the example of like that might make us create for sugar more,
所以，假设在人际关系中，如果你和你的伴侣吵架，而他们并不特别理解，而且，你知道，他们自己也过得很糟糕，那么这会产生紧张。这增加了压力。这然后反馈到我们的生理中。所以我们然后，你知道，有了这种像滚雪球一样的不同因素，反馈到，你知道，生理上的基线变化。然后我在书中提出的观点之一是，有时这些，你知道，我们无法真正控制的生理变化，只是事情发生的方式，最终引导我们走上对我们来说并不特别有帮助的道路。所以关于月经，我想我举的例子是，这可能会让我们更渴望糖分，
but then having that extra sugar can then actually have an impact on our hormone levels and have an impact on our body and how it's processing different things, which actually can have impacts on our mood and make our mood worse. And even, I think, exacerbate pain depending on, yeah, obviously it's different for different people. But so a lot of the time what's happening below the surface are processes that we're being steered towards because of our physiology in ways that actually don't serve us and when we understand some of the mechanisms and we can identify that we can choose different options which isn't always easy often it's not easy at all but it actually can interrupt some of these psychobiological loops yeah it can and i was being a little
但摄入额外的糖分实际上会对我们的激素水平产生影响，并对我们的身体以及它处理不同事物的方式产生影响，这实际上会对我们的情绪产生影响，并使我们的情绪恶化。甚至，我想，加剧疼痛，取决于，是的，显然这对不同的人来说是不同的。但所以很多时候在表面之下发生的是我们因为生理原因而被引导向的那些实际上并不服务于我们的过程，当我们理解了一些机制并且我们可以识别出这一点时，我们可以选择不同的选项，这并不总是容易的，通常一点也不容易，但它实际上可以中断其中一些心理生物学循环。是的，它可以，而且我当时有点
bit cheeky because obviously a supportive partner is always what we would want for someone but it was yeah, the kind of reaction of sugar and estrogen and that interaction that can actually potentially make things worse that I hadn't actually realized. And you also talk about another concept called biology balancing behaviour. How might, what does that look like? How might that show up for us? So this relates to a concept that I talk about in the book called Allostatic Lode. So Alastatic Lod is this cumulative physiological buildup of stress in the body. And that can happen across lots of different biomarkers. So changes to cortisol, not always in one direction. It can be a buildup of cortisol. It can be a reduction in cortisol.
厚脸皮，因为显然一个支持性的伴侣总是我们希望某人拥有的，但那是，是的，糖和雌激素的那种反应以及那种相互作用，实际上可能让事情变得更糟，我之前并没有真正意识到。你还谈到了另一个概念，叫做“生物平衡行为”。那是什么样子的？它如何为我们表现出来？这与我在书中谈到的一个概念有关，叫做“异位负荷”。异位负荷是身体中压力的累积生理堆积。这可以在许多不同的生物标志物中发生。所以皮质醇的变化，并不总是朝一个方向。它可以是皮质醇的堆积。它可以是皮质醇的减少。
It can be changed in our heart rate variability, our blood pressure, our cholesterol, lots of different biomarkers of allostatic load. And essentially, alistatic load can happen because we have too much stress, which is one that's quite intuitive for us to think about without adequate reprieve or moments of restoration and replenishment, and that builds and builds. But allostatic load can also happen because we get insufficient stress. So our kind of systems aren't worked out enough. Essentially, what we're aiming for is flexibility across lots of different systems, not just our nervous system, but our different regulatory systems like our cardiovascular system, our metabolic system, neuroendocrine system, immune system, we want it to be nice and responsive, which means kind of
它可以是我们的心率变异性、血压、胆固醇的变化，许多不同的异位负荷生物标志物。本质上，异位负荷的发生是因为我们有太多的压力，这是我们直观地认为的，没有足够的喘息或恢复和补充的时刻，它就会不断堆积。但异位负荷也可能因为我们得到的压力不足而发生。所以我们的系统没有得到足够的锻炼。本质上，我们追求的是跨越许多不同系统的灵活性，不仅仅是我们的神经系统，还有我们不同的调节系统，如心血管系统、代谢系统、神经内分泌系统、免疫系统，我们希望它很好且反应灵敏，这意味着，你知道，
like activating and deactivating and what have you. And so when it comes to, you know, behaviours that serve our body to balance things across these regulatory systems, we need to be thinking about this principle of consistent little and often, rather than these big overhauls. So So society we're not really socialized to this because if you think about how holidays work, even in school periods, you have like a big wedge of term time and then you get two weeks off. And then you have a big wedge of term time and then you get a week off and so on and so forth. And then at some point you get six weeks off. So it's very much just like condensed, kill it, learn, get assessed.
激活和去激活等等。所以当涉及到，你知道，服务于我们身体以平衡这些调节系统行为时，我们需要考虑这种“持续、少量、经常”的原则，而不是这些大的彻底改革。所以社会我们并没有真正社会化到这一点，因为如果你想想假期是如何运作的，即使在学校期间，你也有很大一段学期时间，然后你有两周休息。然后你有一大段学期时间，然后你有一周休息，以此类推。然后在某个时候你有六周休息。所以它非常像压缩、杀死、学习、被评估。
Then you can have two weeks off. Then you're back into it. So what we would call like a boom-bust pattern, also the working day, the way, you know, we're socialized to have it is you get up, you then do like a big wedge of work throughout the day and then theoretically you can have the evening off, although many people don't have the evening off. And then same pattern throughout the week. Throughout the week, you do all your work and then on the weekend theoretically you can relax. And because we live in this kind of capitalist society, it's very much about, you know, cramming productivity and output. and earn your rest. So what this means is for biology balance behavior, we're not very good at balancing different behaviors and habits. We tend to, you know, have these big condensed periods
然后你可以休息两周。然后你又回到了它。所以我们称之为“繁荣-萧条”模式，工作日也是如此，你知道，我们被社会化教育认为它应该是你起床，然后你在一天中做一大块工作，然后理论上你可以休息晚上，尽管许多人晚上没有休息。然后整个星期都是同样的模式。整个星期，你做完所有的工作，然后在周末理论上你可以放松。因为我们生活在这种资本主义社会中，它非常关于，你知道，挤压生产力和产出，并赚取你的休息。所以这意味着对于生物平衡行为，我们不太擅长平衡不同的行为和习惯。我们倾向于，你知道，有这些大的压缩时期
of doing different things that are completely disparate. So it's do something towards productivity and then rest. If we think about how that then kind of feeds into what we're thinking about is important to replenish our bodies, we don't necessarily think about the habits that need to be sprinkled throughout our days, throughout our weeks, consistently. That includes things like restorative rest, not just a lack of doing anything, which for most people now, that means they are still doing something, they're picking up their phones and they're scrolling or they're watching TV because they're so zoned out because their brain's overtaxed. So the principles of biology balance behavior are really simple.
做完全不同的事情。所以它是做一些有助于生产力的事情，然后休息。如果我们考虑这如何反馈到我们认为对补充我们的身体很重要的事情上，我们不一定考虑需要在我们的日子里、我们的星期里持续撒入的习惯。这包括像恢复性休息，不仅仅是缺乏做任何事情，这对现在大多数人来说，意味着他们仍然在做某事，他们拿起手机滚动，或者他们看电视，因为他们太麻木了，因为他们的大脑负担过重。所以生物平衡行为的原则非常简单。
There are things that everybody knows about. You know, it's eating regularly, eating, you know, healthily, having some movement, socially connecting, getting outside in nature, doing things for pleasure, all of those cornerstones that we can readily think of. But it's about actually trying to apply them. in our lives in a way that is consistent and more regular rather than I'm going to do all of this stuff that accumulates this allostatic load potentially and then, you know, then I can do that. So it's not groundbreaking stuff in terms of what it is, but it's more in our approach of how we
这些是每个人都知道的事情。你知道，这是规律饮食、健康饮食、进行一些运动、社交联系、到大自然中去、做一些为了快乐的事情，所有那些我们可以轻易想到的基石。但关键在于真正尝试应用它们。在我们的生活中，以一种持续且更规律的方式，而不是“我要做所有这些可能积累这种异位负荷的事情，然后，你知道，然后我可以做那个”。所以就它是什么而言，这不是开创性的东西，但它更多是在我们如何
allow ourselves to engage in it. I'm with you. So my youngest son, who's nine, he gets migraines. And so this kind of gives me some evidence that actually my approach only allowing a half an hour fluctuation in his bedtime, even on holidays, really, unless we're a way away, because that means we're less likely to get migraines. So that builds up that evidence base for why I'm doing that then. Absolutely. It's so key that, you know, yeah, sleep is a big one. And especially when you have something like migraine or chronic headache, circadian rhythm plays a massive role. And having that regular kind of sleep window wake time just really, really helps a foundation. Obviously, it's not the whole picture. But without it, then everything else is a bit more different.
允许自己参与其中的方法上。我同意你的观点。所以我的小儿子，他九岁，他患有偏头痛。所以这给了我一些证据，证明实际上我只允许他在睡觉时间有半小时的波动，即使在假期，除非我们离得很远，因为这意味着我们不太可能患偏头痛。所以这建立了为什么我那样做的证据基础。绝对是。这是关键，你知道，是的，睡眠是一个大问题。特别是当你患有偏头痛或慢性头痛时，昼夜节律起着巨大的作用。拥有那种规律的睡眠窗口唤醒时间真的非常有帮助。显然，这不是全部。但没有它，那么其他一切就有点不同了。
So yeah, absolutely. Yeah. And there can be so many decisions to make when you're just living a modern life, but also when you've got health conditions or diagnoses, more and more decisions. And I think it's said that women carry more of the mental load and make more decisions about household things day-to-day. If you are not a woman and you're listening to all this watching this, feel free to disagree. But that's, I think, generally said to be understood.
所以是的，绝对是。是的，当你过着现代生活时，可能会有太多的决定要做，而且当你患有健康状况或诊断时，会有越来越多的决定。而且我认为有人说女性承担了更多的心理负担，并对日常家庭事务做出更多的决定。如果你不是女性，并且你在听这一切看着这个，请随意不同意。但我认为，这通常被认为是公认的。
But I really like something in the book where you talk about glutamate, which is not something I've ever heard of or considered. Tell us about glutamate. Yeah, so glutamate is this, I think it's a protein that gets released as we're, well, from a lot of things, but when we're making decisions, we have this buildup of glutamate. And the more decisions we make, the more that's produced. And the relationship is, the more glutamate build up, the more we require sleep to clear it. And then we start again and we were theoretically back at our kind of baseline and so on and so forth.
但我真的很喜欢书中的一些内容，你谈到了谷氨酸，这不是我听说过或考虑过的东西。告诉我们关于谷氨酸的事。是的，所以谷氨酸是这个，我认为它是一种蛋白质，当我们，嗯，从很多事情中释放出来，但当我们做决定时，我们有这种谷氨酸的堆积。我们做的决定越多，产生的就越多。这种关系是，谷氨酸堆积越多，我们越需要睡眠来清除它。然后我们重新开始，理论上我们回到了我们的基线，以此类推。
And what people don't really know is that relationship between those cognitive processes of decision making, every new decision then, you know, is a metabolic toll essentially and influences this buildup of glutamate. And like you say, in our modern day lives, there's so many micro, mini decisions. So that's all influencing this very physical process. And then if you add on top of that things that we do to try and zone out, like phone use, that actually brings in more micro decisions. Do I want to watch this? Do I want to press like? Do I comment do I want to make? Do I want to go to the next one? What does this mean about this? Oh, that makes sense. On to the next one. So even our ways of kind of zoning out actually go the opposite direction in terms of like what they do to us physically.
人们并不真正知道的是决策的那些认知过程之间的关系，每一个新的决定然后，你知道，本质上是一个代谢代价，并影响这种谷氨酸的堆积。就像你说的，在我们的现代生活中，有太多的微小决定。所以这一切都在影响这个非常物理的过程。然后如果你在上面加上我们为了尝试麻木自己而做的事情，比如手机使用，那实际上带来了更多的微小决定。我想看这个吗？我想按赞吗？我评论我想做吗？我想去下一个吗？这关于这个意味着什么？哦，那有道理。到下一个。所以即使我们那种麻木自己的方式实际上在物理上对我们所做的事情上走向了相反的方向。
Rather than restore, they actually deplete. And then if we add into the mixed chronic illness and decisions about health and decisions about your body and trying to home into what a particular sensation means, you can see how that quickly escalates how many different micro decisions and thinking processes you have to engage in and how that then direct. can correspond to fatigue. Yeah, absolutely. Should we be then trying to down tools a bit more often and have no decisions? You know, would reading a book still cause glutamate to be released
它们不仅没有恢复，实际上还在消耗。然后如果我们把慢性病和关于健康的决定以及关于你的身体的决定以及尝试专注于某种感觉意味着什么加入到混合中，你可以看到这如何迅速升级你必须参与的多少不同的微小决定和思维过程，以及这如何直接对应于疲劳。是的，绝对是。那么我们是否应该尝试更频繁地放下工具，不做决定？你知道，读书仍然会导致谷氨酸释放吗
or not so much? Not so much because we're being led along and we're reading. And yes, we might have other little thought processes, but we're engaged in something more akin to like a flow state of our imagination kind of going with the book. But I think I talk about this in the book as well. I'm pretty sure I must talk about this in the book somewhere. There's something called the default mode network, which is like a network of different brain regions that work together.
还是没那么多？没那么多，因为我们被引导着，我们在阅读。是的，我们可能有其他小的思维过程，但我们参与的事情更类似于我们想象力随着书本流动的状态。但我认为我在书中也谈到了这一点。我很确定我一定在书中的某个地方谈到了这一点。有一种东西叫做默认模式网络，它是一组协同工作的大脑区域。
And essentially, when we're engaged in goal directed thinking, the default mode network is not active. So we're engaged in, you know, the cognitive processes that would lead to this buildup of glutamate, and that's quite metabolically heavy. When we're allowing ourselves just to freethink and we're not trying to analyze or problem solve or, you know, do all of those things that we're so readily doing by just our kind of automatic pilot. So that might be like having a daydream or just, you know, sitting there allowing the thoughts
本质上，当我们进行目标导向的思考时，默认模式网络是不活跃的。所以我们参与的是那些会导致谷氨酸堆积的认知过程，这在代谢上是非常沉重的。当我们允许自己自由思考，而不是试图分析、解决问题，或者做那些我们自动驾驶般习惯做的事情时，比如做白日梦，或者只是坐在那里让思绪流淌，
to go, which not many of us have time for, prioritise, that's when our default mode network activates. And the default mode network activates in that cognitive state of like free flowing thought, not goal directed. And the benefits of that default mode network activating is that it allows us to emotionally regulate. It allows our brain to be more creative. It actually ends up helping us problem solve. It might not be right in that exact moment, but I think about it as like there's pieces of the puzzle line all the way around your different kind of brain regions and networks. And when you're kind of engaging goal directed thinking, sometimes that can be really strategic and be like this bit, this bit, this bit, okay, brilliant. But often we're just like, oh my God, I've got no time.
这正是我们默认模式网络激活的时候，而我们中很少有人有时间或优先考虑这一点。默认模式网络在那种自由流动的思维状态下激活，而不是目标导向的。默认模式网络激活的好处在于它允许我们进行情绪调节，让大脑更具创造力，实际上它最终有助于我们解决问题。可能不是在当下那一刻，但我认为这就像拼图碎片散落在你大脑的不同区域和网络中。当你进行目标导向的思考时，有时这可能非常具有策略性，比如“这个部分，那个部分，好的，太棒了”，但通常我们只是觉得“天哪，我没时间了”。
And is that, is it that bit? Is it that bit? Whereas when we're allowing our default mode network to activate regularly, our brain's kind of like slowly turning over and it's pulling that bit. It's in that bit and they're getting a little bit closer and then before you know it like days passed or some hours have passed and then you can suddenly see it more clearly and people will have experienced that when they're like really trying to figure something out then they go for a walk and they come back and they're like you know what let me try this and it works you know that's that's the default mode network in in action so there's so many different benefits of that default mode network activation, but it involves us doing something that's now quite counterintuitive,
是这部分吗？还是那部分？然而，当我们允许默认模式网络定期激活时，大脑就像在缓慢地运转，它在拉动那部分，在拉动这部分，它们越来越接近，不知不觉中，几天或几小时过去了，你突然能看得更清楚了。人们都有过这样的经历：当他们真的在努力想通某件事时，去散个步，回来后就会说“你知道吗，让我试试这个”，然后它就奏效了。这就是默认模式网络在起作用。所以默认模式网络的激活有很多好处，但它需要我们做一些现在看来相当反直觉的事情，
especially because we don't have that downtime if we're using a lot of digital technology when we're not engaged in our tasks and our obligations. So one of the things that I kind of expand on in the book is it is really important to have just many moments of allowing your brain to be free-flowing. And that can actually be very threatening to a lot of people when there's a lot of difficult emotions, a lot of difficult thought processes. So you can set it up so that it feels safer. That might be like listening to music that stimulates a particular mood or it might be just watching the birds out of the window. So, you know, you've got a benevolent kind of focus and then your brain can do its thing in the background.
特别是当我们不处理任务和义务时，如果使用大量数字技术，我们就没有那种停机时间。所以我在书中扩展的一点是，拥有许多让大脑自由流动的时刻非常重要。当有很多困难的情绪和困难的思维过程时，这实际上对许多人来说可能非常具有威胁性。所以你可以进行设置，让它感觉更安全。这可能就像听能激发特定情绪的音乐，或者只是看着窗外的鸟儿。这样你就拥有了一种仁慈的专注，然后你的大脑就可以在后台做它自己的事情了。
But it's really crucial that we make that a safe activity to do regularly. Yeah, it feels like it's a very important user manual for the brain, all of this stuff, really. And sometimes we can be our own worst enemy, can't we? And it's that idea of the mind and the body, which you described in the book, when you're communicating fearfully but also reactively. Could you give us a little example, perhaps using, you know, recurrent UTI infections, to give us an idea of how that might play out? Yes, so I can use my own example, really.
但至关重要的是，我们要让这成为一种可以定期进行的、安全的活动。是的，这一切感觉就像是大脑的一本非常重要的用户手册。有时我们可能是自己最大的敌人，不是吗？这就是你在书中描述的关于身心的概念，当你以恐惧但又被动的方式进行交流时。你能给我们举个小例子吗，也许用复发性尿路感染（UTI）来让我们了解这可能是如何发生的？好的，我可以用我自己的例子来说明。
So I think the first thing to recognize as well, going back to the point that we made at the beginning, we will so quickly assume self-blame and like we're doing something wrong if we're having particular thoughts or feelings. We'll claim that as like a fault of our own. And we have to recognize it's not. It's natural. Just like the physical sensation is something that we can't control at the outset. It's just there. So is the natural thought processing that comes with it. what's important is we know that we can interrupt things going forward, maybe not acutely in that very moment, but when we become aware of it, we already start changing things and then when we start to practice relating to it in a different way, we can start changing things. But the default
我认为首先要认识到的一点是，回到我们开头提到的观点，如果我们有特定的想法或感受，我们会非常迅速地进行自我指责，认为自己在做错事。我们会将其归咎为自己的过错。我们必须认识到事实并非如此。这是自然的。就像身体感觉是我们一开始无法控制的一样，它就在那里。随之而来的自然思维过程也是如此。重要的是我们要知道，我们可以从现在开始打断这些过程，也许不是在当下那一刻，但当我们意识到这一点时，我们就已经开始改变了，当我们开始练习以不同的方式与之相处时，我们就可以开始改变事情。但默认模式
isn't a character flaw, it's just natural physiological reactions to something threatening. So for me, when I was getting these horrible symptoms, which are very threatening in their own right and very disruptive and feel awful. So let's say that kind of burning sensation and I feel like I can't get off the toilet. I will get that panic in my chest, in my stomach even. I will then automatically be focusing on this sensation. Oh my gosh, it's terrible. I can't move like this. My brain then skisks. ahead, you need to be at work in 45 minutes, how are you going to get to work if you're feeling like this? Oh my gosh, you'll have to take another sick day. They're going to be really angry with you. What if this doesn't clear up by tomorrow? What if this keeps happening? So on and so forth. And you can see, just even me describing those thoughts, they're fair enough thoughts. You know, I need money to survive. I need to keep my bosses happy to keep my job. So like, it's not like any of this is unfair cognitive processing and the panic is just natural.
并不是性格缺陷，它只是对威胁性事物的自然生理反应。对我来说，当我出现这些可怕的症状时，它们本身就非常有威胁性，非常具有破坏性，感觉很糟糕。假设那种灼烧感，我觉得我无法离开厕所。我的胸口甚至胃里会感到恐慌。然后我会自动专注于这种感觉。“天哪，太可怕了，我动不了。”我的大脑随后会超前思考：“你45分钟后要上班，如果你感觉这样，你怎么去上班？天哪，你得再请一天病假。他们会非常生气的。如果明天还没好怎么办？如果这种情况一直发生怎么办？”等等。你可以看到，即使是我描述这些想法，它们也是合理的想法。你知道，我需要钱来生存，我需要让老板满意来保住工作。所以，这并不是说这些是不公平的认知过程，恐慌只是自然的。
But the problem is what all of that surmounts to is the attention remains fixated on two focuses of threat. The thoughts of projecting what the threats might be in the future and the physical threat in the moment. And then you're not really getting an opportunity for any alternative to bring in safety in that moment. You're trapped between a rock and a hard place, your thoughts and your physical sensations. So one of the foundational things that I have people practice when we first start working together is trying to get out of the habit of sinking in those moments of acute panic and physical discomfort and often counterintuitively to a lot of people starting to get into the feelings and the body to then soothe and calm the system down because when we're in that autonomic,
但问题在于，所有这些加起来的结果是，注意力仍然固定在两个威胁焦点上：投射未来可能出现的威胁的想法，以及当下的身体威胁。然后你真的没有机会引入任何替代方案来在当下带来安全感。你被困在进退两难的境地，被你的思想和身体感觉所困。所以，当我们刚开始合作时，我让人们练习的基础之一就是尝试改掉在急性恐慌和身体不适时刻沉沦的习惯，并且反直觉地，对许多人来说，开始进入感受和身体，以安抚和冷静系统，因为当我们处于那种自主神经系统、
sympathetic nervous system zone, it's just going to feed those fearful brain processes and we're just going to get trapped in all of the understandable cognitive spirals. So, you know, there's so many different ways that we can physiologically soothe, but we know one staple is just changing the breath, trying to extend the exhale. So it's longer than the inhale, slowing everything down. That directly feeds back into this sympathetic nervous system and starts to balance things. But it also gives a different attentional point of focus. So it doesn't have to be on the thought stream or the physical sensations in the bladder. And when there's a little bit of space there and it's not quite so frantic, then we can step into options, you know, and the options
交感神经系统区域时，它只会助长那些恐惧的大脑过程，我们只会陷入所有可以理解的认知螺旋中。所以，你知道，我们可以通过许多不同的方式进行生理上的安抚，但我们知道一个主要方法就是改变呼吸，尝试延长呼气，使其比吸气更长，放慢一切。这直接反馈到交感神经系统并开始平衡事物。但它也提供了一个不同的注意力焦点。所以它不必集中在思想流或膀胱的身体感觉上。当那里有一点空间，不再那么狂乱时，我们就可以选择方案，你知道，方案
in that moment of acute panic or acute crisis, we want to ring fence so that they're very much in the present. They're not projecting forward. We can get to that stage, but we give ourselves permission of like, what's the thing now that's going to serve me? Shall I stay on the toilet for a little bit longer and see how this goes. Shall I get a sashay? You know, that might soothe my bladder. Shall I go, you know, get somebody to bring me some water? So we can think about the here and now a little bit more. And then, and then from there, you know, we can add in different things to help. But I think one of the expectations that people have is my intervention that I have in this moment has to switch everything right around. Otherwise, it's failed and it's not worth it. And that
在急性恐慌或急性危机的时刻，我们想要划定范围，使它们非常处于当下。它们不是向未来投射。我们可以达到那个阶段，但我们给自己许可，比如：“现在有什么事情能为我服务？”我应该在厕所多待一会儿看看情况吗？我应该拿个热水袋吗？你知道，那可能会安抚我的膀胱。我应该去叫人给我拿点水吗？所以我们可以多考虑一下此时此地。然后，从那里开始，我们可以加入不同的东西来提供帮助。但我认为人们有的一个期望是，我在这一刻采取的干预措施必须彻底扭转一切，否则就是失败的，不值得的。而那
And that's one thing that then ends up keeping us stuck because often we don't have a route for that in the moment. But if we have a route for calming the system down a little bit, that opens a little option over here, which then can open a little option over here and so on and so forth. And all of these things take practice for them to work quicker and more enduringly. Yeah. And you've really wonderfully described how you can take what feels like something that's outside of your control and then be able to pull on the threads that you actually do have
而那正是最终让我们陷入困境的一件事，因为通常我们在当下没有那样的途径。但如果我们有途径让系统稍微冷静下来，那就会在这里打开一个小选项，然后可以在这里打开一个小选项，以此类推。所有这些事情都需要练习，才能让它们工作得更快、更持久。是的。你非常精彩地描述了如何将感觉超出你控制范围的事情，然后能够拉动你实际上拥有的那些线索，
some control about that then really make you feel better about the whole thing. And then you can get those moments of deep exhale, which then actually are going to make you feel ultimately better anyway, because your system isn't so stressed and aggravated. Yeah, absolutely. And people really surprised themselves of how much influence they have over their state, even when they're at very heightened levels of panic or physical discomfort. And often when I'm working with people, we're doing it together to begin with. And I'm even surprised at how quickly their state changes. And when they've had that experience once, whether it's in company or on their own,
你确实有一些控制权，这会让你对整件事感觉更好。然后你可以获得那些深呼吸的时刻，这实际上最终会让你感觉更好，因为你的系统没有那么紧张和焦虑。是的，绝对是这样。人们真的对自己即使在极度恐慌或身体不适时，对自己的状态有多大的影响力感到惊讶。通常当我与人们一起工作时，我们一开始是一起做的。即使是我也对他们状态改变的速度感到惊讶。当他们有过一次那种经历时，无论是在陪伴下还是独自一人，
you know, their brain and their body has a point of reference of like, I've been there once, I can get there again. And even that creates a little bit of hope and curiosity in a moment that otherwise is full of despair and feeling trapped. Yeah, I think for me, you know, reading your book, it really is a really nice manual of hope for people that might be feeling despair. So yeah, if people want to grab a copy, check it out. Is there an audio book as well? Is there an e-book?
你知道，他们的大脑和身体都有一个参考点，比如“我曾经到过那里，我可以再次到达那里”。即使是这一点，也在一个充满绝望和被困感的时刻创造了一点希望和好奇心。是的，我想对我来说，读你的书，它确实是一本非常好的希望手册，适合那些可能感到绝望的人。所以，如果人们想买一本，去看看吧。有有声书吗？有电子书吗？
Yes, there's an e-book, everything. All of them are available. And it's called It's All in Your Body, a practical roadmap to healing through mind-body connection by Dr. Sula. Wengasson. Where can people learn more about you and your work? Are you on Instagram, Sula? I'm on Instagram. My handle is at the underscore health underscore psychologist underscore. I have a YouTube channel which is at the health psychologist and it's got a lot of episodes of a podcast of mine that's just come out which is called How We Really Feel, which is a deep dive particularly into bladder and pelvic. conditions but it's very relevant to people navigating chronic illness generally as well
是的，有电子书，什么都有。所有这些都可以买到。书名是《一切都在你的身体里：通过身心连接实现治愈的实用路线图》，作者是Sula Wengasson博士。人们在哪里可以了解更多关于你和你工作的信息？你在Instagram上吗，Sula？我在Instagram上。我的账号是@the_underscore_health_underscore_psychologist_underscore。我有一个YouTube频道，是@the_health_psychologist，上面有很多我刚出的播客剧集，叫做《我们真实的感受》，这是一个深入探讨膀胱和盆腔疾病的节目，但它对于那些通常在应对慢性疾病的人来说也非常相关，
and then there's my website which has got lots of free resources which is healthpsychologist.co. com. Amazing. I will make sure that all of that is linked in the show notes. Thank you so much for your time and for illuminating our audience on this really, really important area. Thank you so much for having me. You're so welcome. Thank you so much again to my guest. Please do check out her book. It's all in your body if you think that might be useful for you. And a little plea, as an author myself, if you ever read a book that you really like, please do leave a Good Reads Review, an Amazon review, something that helps people know it's a genuinely helpful resource. If you've got ideas for future episodes that you'd like
然后是我的网站，上面有很多免费资源，网址是healthpsychologist.co.com。太棒了。我会确保所有这些都链接在节目说明中。非常感谢你的时间，并为我们的听众阐明了这个非常、非常重要的领域。非常感谢你邀请我。不客气。再次非常感谢我的嘉宾。如果你认为这本书对你有用，请务必看看她的书《一切都在你的身体里》。还有一个小小的请求，作为一名作者，如果你读到一本你非常喜欢的书，请务必留下Goodreads评论、亚马逊评论，或者任何能帮助人们知道这是一本真正有用的资源的东西。如果你对未来想看到的剧集有想法，
to see me hosting psychology, actually, I would love to hear from you. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, wherever you are on social media, or you can just pop a comment on any of my YouTube videos. If you are interested about the experiences of people on their way to becoming qualified psychologists, I think you will like the Clinical Psychologist Collective, which despite the title doesn't just feature stories of clinical psychologists. We have another couple of different psychology disciplines in there as well. You can get that from Amazon and please, like I said, if you do like the book, I love it if you'd rate and review it.
我非常乐意听取你的意见。我是Marianne Trent博士，无论你在社交媒体上的哪里，或者你可以在我的任何YouTube视频下发表评论。如果你对人们成为合格心理学家的经历感兴趣，我想你会喜欢《临床心理学家集体》，尽管书名如此，但它不仅仅包含临床心理学家的故事。我们里面还有其他几种不同的心理学学科。你可以从亚马逊上买到它，请像我说的那样，如果你确实喜欢这本书，如果你能给它评分和评论，我会很高兴的。
If you've enjoyed health psychology, I think you'll really like this video that I did hear with Nicola O'Donnell, who was at the time a trainee health psychologist, but is now fully qualified as a health psychologist. If you're a fan of the podcast and you'd like early access, please do consider subscribing to the podcast,
如果你喜欢健康心理学，我想你会非常喜欢我在这里与Nicola O'Donnell做的这个视频，她当时是一名实习健康心理学家，但现在已经完全具备了健康心理学家的资格。如果你是这个播客的粉丝，并且想要提前收听，请考虑订阅这个播客，
which you can do on Captivate, on Patreon, on YouTube, and on Apple Podcasts. I think I'm a pretty good judge of character and I love sharing tips and tricks with people which genuinely help them to run their clinical practices more efficiently. This episode is supported by write-up and they're a brand I've been using in my own clinical practice for over six years. I really do genuinely rate them and use the write-up platform for each and every clinic session I book or conduct. That's why I'm so happy to be working with them. In case you don't know already, write-up is an all-in-one practice management
你可以在Captivate、Patreon、YouTube和Apple Podcasts上订阅。我认为我看人很准，我喜欢与人们分享真正能帮助他们更有效地经营临床实践的技巧和窍门。本期节目由Write-up支持，他们是我在自己的临床实践中已经使用了超过六年的品牌。我确实真心评价他们，并为我预订或进行的每一次临床会议使用Write-up平台。这就是为什么我很高兴与他们合作。如果你还不知道，Write-up是一个一体化的实践管理
platform built in the UK for UK clinicians. So that's your diary, your client records, your notes, your invoicing, your secure messaging, all in one place, all GDPR compliant, all designed around the way we actually practice. Also, news just in, they've recently launched an AI scribe that drafts your session notes for you and a tap to pay app that turns your smartphone into a card reader. Both are the kind of small changes that quietly give you hours back every week. But don't worry if you don't want to use all of those features, you don't have to either. If you've been meaning to sort your admin out or you're stuck wrestling with a system that wasn't built for you, take a look at writeup.com. That's
平台，在英国为英国临床医生构建。所以那是你的日记、客户记录、笔记、发票、安全消息，都在一个地方，完全符合GDPR，完全围绕我们实际实践的方式设计。此外，刚收到的消息，他们最近推出了一个为你起草会议笔记的AI记录员，以及一个将你的智能手机变成读卡器的点击支付应用程序。两者都是那种能悄悄地每周为你节省数小时的小改变。但如果你不想使用所有这些功能，也不用担心，你也不必使用。如果你一直想整理你的行政工作，或者被一个不是为你构建的系统困住，看看writeup.com。那是
W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P dot com. And when you use my code, Marianne 30, you can access a free 30-day trial with 30% off for six months for up to six users. What's not? to like. Now on with the show. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P点com。当你使用我的代码Marianne 30时，你可以获得30天的免费试用，并为最多六个用户提供六个月的七折优惠。有什么不喜欢的呢？现在继续节目。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。